the now world-famous capuchin monkey is  being kept at this animal shelter in  Munich 14 week old Malley made headlines  around the world  when he was confiscated from his famous  owner at Munich Airport shelter workers  say they were asked by customs officers  to care for the primate but that it took  them four days to find out the animal  belonged to a pop star authorities have  given Justin Bieber four weeks to  provide the proper documentation for his  pet if he hasn't gotten in touch with us  by then the customs office will probably  release the monkey into our care  indefinitely then we'll find it a good  home but it won't be someone's house  where the animals kept alone it'll be a  place that's appropriate for the species  for now Malley has this stuffed animal  to keep him company  Bieber reportedly received the monkey as  a birthday present workers at the  shelter say Malley was separated from  his mother far too young and that he's  using the toy as a surrogate